هذا المساء ، اجتماعنا الأول في 28 مايو
فعلنا ذلك من أجل
أنا هنا وأنا هنا أنت هنا أيضًا
أقسم بالله حتى النهاية
سأقاتل ، هذا صحيح ، لكنني سأخسره أردوغان
في هذه الانتخابات ، وهي استفتاء
لم تحصل على تصويت على الثقة
18 من أصل 31 نائبا في اسطنبول
واحد منهم ليس من حزبنا يستقيل غدا
ما هو الخط الذي يتم صنعه كمال
يجب أن يستقيل السيد هذا اليوم
كنا نقول اليوم هو اليوم وإلى الشارع
خرج التصويت قائلا إن رجب طيب أردوغان خسر
نحن الوحيدين الخاسرين هنا
نحن نبكي
يمكننا أن نقول ذلك بأمان
مرشحنا الرئاسي السيد.
Kılıçdaroğlu بلدنا الليلة
سيتم إعلانه رئيسا
[موسيقى]
حسنة لأمتنا
نحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا للحصول على النتائج.
سنفعل هذا أو ذاك الآن
نحن لا نقول أبدا أننا سندعم
لن نقول
[موسيقى]